thank you
Rescuers race to search for survivors
following an explosion during afternoon
prayers at a mosque and Peshawar
the blast so powerful the roof collapsed
police say hundreds of people were in
the mosque at the time
[Applause]
those able to pull themselves out from
under the rubble
[Applause]
the injured and they were taken to
hospital the dead bodies are all inside
the mosque buried under the rubber
foreign
[Music]
hospitals across the provincial capital
are on high alert
[Music]
many of the casualties are members of
Pakistan Security Services gathered for
daily prayers
a target of the attack the neighborhood
Mosque of a housing complex in one of
the most tightly controlled parts of the
city home to members of security
services including the police Army and
bomb disposal units the incident is a
major security breach
the Pakistani Taliban says it is
retaliation for the killing of Khalid
khorasani one of its founding members
and a senior leader in Afghanistan last
year
and it's warned more attacks are coming
Al Jazeera